what's going on guys we are coming to
you with breaking news we like many of
you watched the live feed of the Star
Wars Celebration and there was new Star
Wars Force awakens footage JJ Abrams
gave us a little gift we're gonna talk
about it right now we have a very cool
group of dudes to talk about it with
first he's a good friend of the show
from belated medium Michael barity
thanks for having me oh thanks for
coming in ah oh he's a screen junkie
himself Jason Inman excited to be on
this whole bearded panel and oh your
friend and mine Andy signor hi good to
see you so first let me ask this they
gave us a lot more but are we
disappointed at all that wasn't the full
trailer and it was just the teaser or is
that to be expected I thought that was
the perfect teaser trailer yeah I think
it was the perfect amount without
spoiling too much and I see I liked it
better than the first one which I feel
was a little too not enough yeah this to
me
was perfect overall let's so go down the
line give us your thoughts on what was
just dropped on us uh really excited for
just the evolutions of a lot of things
we saw a new storm trooper the new storm
troopers think this was this was our
first really solid look at it also act
celebration they had like a bunch of
people come out as storm in the
stormtrooper uniforms an actual
stormtrooper so you could catch oh the
the helmets are more angular and like
try or triangular in nature which i
think is really really sleek and cool
then in the trailer we saw the chrome
trooper yeah it just looks really dope
interesting yeah to about all the
stormtroopers is in a lot of his shots
especially the one that was driving the
TIE fighter he had red marks on his
helmet and the chrome trooper in the
same shot walking down the hallway there
were red markings on the hallway there
was a shot of snow if it was in front of
a red flag what is the deal with these
red tribal markings yeah so Adam do you
say would you say that's the next
incarnation of the Empire after taking
that beating my guess is that I think
the Empire is not the Empire we knew
from the original trilogy and maybe to
survive they've had to like partner with
some unsavory elements they're gonna be
different I think it was that the shot
of them all turning there's the symbol
behind them that is not the symbol
specific to the Empire
seems like a step up it's more fracture
but it also has the same like six sides
that the Empire symbol had and has some
allusions to the Black Sun the criminal
empire of the Star Wars universe insane
crazy insane Star Wars murder yeah which
is very great that the attention and
they're doing those names okay so you
mentioned the chrome trooper more badass
throw this out there
chrome trooper or kylo Ren with the
cross lightsaber taking the mask I'm
diggin I actually like the lightsaber
now I'm kind of glad they sort of teased
it and got all the Hubble ooh now we can
like actually like alright that's kind
of cool-looking
yeah but to me that part of the excites
me the most is these little twists on
things that we already know like we see
this lightsaber that Luke hands it or it
could be luke could be somebody somebody
handle a lightsaber to a woman could be
Leia could be his daughter during that
narration and it looks like Anakin
Skywalker's original lightsaber from the
prequels though the lightsaber that Luke
got from obi-wan Kenobi but we all know
he lost that in Cloud City when his hand
got chopped off so is it a different
lightsaber is it the original lightsaber
from Cloud City if it is that's an
interesting turn of events yeah yeah I
can assume that it's Daisy Ridley
grabbing john boyega's hand in that one
specific shot I think that's pretty safe
to assume especially since later we see
the two of them running away from the
explosion but we don't have the greater
sense of like Oh whose hand is that on
r2d2 but like Michael said it's
interesting too that like we don't even
know what planets have these places like
it looks like Hoth and what it looks
like I used too far we don't know Oni
we're watching it earlier you'd point
out it was a snow planet that the
symbols real empire that they wish they
would have a new planet I mean we've
already seen the team we've got Shang
the desert plant like we now have Yahoo
which is everybody was oh we're back on
Tatooine it's like haha no it's not
Tatooine it's a it's Jack who which is
more of a I guess a graveyard for a lot
of some massive battle and we know
that Daisy Ridley's character is a
scavenger of sorts so that seems like
her is it safe to assume that she's the
daughter of somebody else like I feel
like it feels like that's where its
leading yes yes based off of especially
reshaping was her last name
these things yeah spoiler or not if you
like I like that they're still not
telling us hopefully if that's the next
reveal that they have to give us okay
great I still wanna see the movie
doesn't it's a poor strong in this one
Jason yes okay
the force has been awoken yeah um I also
another interesting thing is that Han
Solo says we're home Chewie we're home
so do they lose the Millennium Falcon is
the Millennium Falcon that part of is it
is it sitting in that sand from that's a
giant battle because it was by a
scavenger found by a scavenger so we've
come through the trailer a little bit is
there anything else that is up for
debate
what about the Darth Vader helmet we saw
I think that that is specifically in
there for the sake of the teaser it is a
little bit melted just like returning
jedi cuz he was he lit his father on
fire I think someone kept it yeah and
who's the weirdo that kept it or the
badass well either way I love seeing it
cuz it's one of the best images in movie
history
eerie iconography that that strikes a
chord with everybody so in that regard
it worked for the trailers purpose a
hundred percent another thing that I
noticed is there's a shot where the
Millennium Falcon is flying on the the
planet desert battle planet jakku maybe
yeah
and it flies in the back tailpipe of one
of these ships and to me it looks like
the all Deranian cruiser that we saw on
a new hope I'm of the belief that it is
the exhaust of an Imperial cruiser I
mean an in either case we're flying into
the exhaust port of a ship yes really
did this make you more excited less
excited or you're just totally pumped
regardless it made me more excited yeah
the first one was great I'm not gonna
brag on it but just felt like it didn't
deliver that sort of moment of like the
vo and it just this had more gravitas
without giving away too much but to me
it was the perfect present I'm more
intrigued I'm really intrigued by these
mysteries now and it really feels now at
this trailer that we are going back home
to the original trilogy more so than the
prequels to that I love that JJ Abrams
described it among other things as a
Western you know cuz that I feel like
the prequels were missing that yeah yeah
this one just feels even even larger in
scope
than anything like the the first teaser
gave us a tonal understanding of where
we'd be showed us a few worlds this
showed us the scope of things and that
is very exciting because we're not in
any capacity going to diplomacy we're
going to the Wars of Star Wars
yes which that's true hope they don't
get stuck in diplomacy again yeah we
won't be touching I'm sure that the
trailers if they do but they're right
maybe showing us the cool parts now and
in the rest of movie is flashlight
chisholm or diploma ii I don't want long
counsel no I don't want any council
meetings what did you think about the
new trailer let us know in the comments
section below
best answer we're gonna send you one of
our new screen junkies now we have a new
shop and if you don't want to wait to
win you can go buy them on district
lines check it out link to the
description below go support your own
heck yes I want to thank Michael Barrett
E Jason Inman Andy signor and I want to
thank you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
hit us all up on Twitter bye bye the
Lannisters are getting ready for a
wedding of their own King Joffrey and
everyone's favorite gold digger Margaery
Tyrell let's face it if it's got a crown
she's down